in the darkest chapter of german history
during a time when incited mobs threw
stones into the windows of innocent shop
owners and women and children were
cruelly humiliated in the open dietrich
bonhoeffer a young pastor began to speak
publicly against the atrocities that the
regime had produced
after years of trying to change people's
minds dietrich bonhoeffer came home one
evening and his own father had to tell
him that two men were waiting in his
room to take him away
in prison bonhoeffer began to reflect on
how his country of poets and thinkers
had turned into a collective of cowards
crooks and criminals
eventually he concluded that the root of
the problem was not malice but stupidity
[Music]
in his famous letters from prison
bonhoeffer argued that stupidity is a
more dangerous enemy of the good than
malice because while one may protest
against evil it can be exposed and
prevented by the use of force
against stupidity we are defenseless
neither protests nor the use of force
accomplish anything here
reasons fall on deaf ears
facts that contradict a stupid person's
prejudgment simply need not be believed
and when they are irrefutable they are
just pushed aside as inconsequential as
incidental
in all this the stupid person is
self-satisfied and being easily
irritated becomes dangerous by going on
the attack
for that reason greater caution is
called for when dealing with a stupid
person than with a malicious one
if we want to know how to get the better
of stupidity we must seek to understand
its nature
this much is certain stupidity is in
essence not an intellectual defect but a
moral one
there are human beings who are
remarkably agile intellectually yet
stupid and others who are intellectually
dull yet anything but stupid
the impression one gains is not so much
that stupidity is a congenital defect
but that under certain circumstances
people are made stupid or rather they
allow this to happen to them
people who live in solitude manifest
this defect less frequently than
individuals in groups and so it would
seem that stupidity is perhaps less a
psychological than a sociological
problem
it becomes apparent that every strong
upsurge of power be it of a political or
religious nature infects a large part of
humankind with stupidity almost as if
this is a sociological psychological law
where the power of the one needs the
stupidity of the other
the process at work here is not that
particular human capacities such as
intellect suddenly fail
instead it seems that under the
overwhelming impact of rising power
humans are deprived of their inner
independence and more or less
consciously give up an autonomous
position
[Music]
the fact that the stupid person is often
stubborn must not blind us from the fact
that he is not independent
in conversation with him one virtually
feels that one is dealing not at all
with him as a person but with slogans
catchwords and the like that have taken
possession of him
he is under a spell blinded misused and
is abused in his very being
having thus become a mindless tool the
stupid person will also be capable of
any evil incapable of seeing that it is
evil
only an act of liberation not
instruction can overcome stupidity
here we must come to terms with the fact
that in most cases a genuine internal
liberation becomes possible only when
external liberation has preceded it
until then we must abandon all attempts
to convince the stupid person
bonhoeffer died due to his involvement
in a plot against adolf hitler at dawn
on the 9th of april 1945
at flossenberg concentration camp just
two weeks before soldiers from the
united states liberated the camp
action springs not from thought but from
a readiness for responsibility
the ultimate test of a moral society is
the kind of world that it leaves to its
children bonhoeffer once said
check the description below to read
bonhoeffer's original text after 10
years
for more information about bonhoeffer or
to download this video without
background music
go to sproutschools.com
[Music]
sprouts videos are published under the
creative commons license that means our
videos are free and anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools governments and
non-profit organizations can also use
them for training online courses or
designing new curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute just visit patreon.com
sprouts even one dollar can make a
difference